[Music]
it's real pleasure to introduce the
speaker today this is the second in this
year's series of presidential fellow
lectures hosted by the presidential
fellow Society at MIT the idea is to
have a series of lectures that to bring
together graduate students and faculty
colleagues from across the institution
to share in some of the exciting
research and issues that are being of
scholarship that are being undertaken on
the campus and it's a real pleasure
today to have Bob Langer from the
Department of Chemical Engineering as
our speaker now Bob graduated from MIT
with a PhD in chemical engineering in
1974 he did a postdoc at the Children's
Hospital with Judith falkman thereafter
and then came back and joined the
faculty here when you look at Bob you
will not think that just looking at him
and thinking about 1974 is in my time
not very long ago what he has
accomplished in the years at MIT if you
read Time magazine or other popular
press you'll see words like father of
modern drug delivery associated with his
name he has invented methods for
delivering large molecules through
membranes into the body and he'll talk
about many of these techniques today
he'll also talk about the applications
and impact of the work which is as
dramatic as the science and engineering
he has won an enormous number of honors
for his research
innumerable honors from professional
societies I think one of the most
outstanding tributes to his work is he
is currently an active member of all
three national academies the National
Academy of Science the National Academy
of Engineering and the Institute of
Edison I may be wrong but I believe Bob
is the only active member of all three
academies he's also won the limo Sun
prize for innovation based on his the
impact the both in a societal way in a
commercial way of his of his many
research accomplishments he holds over
400 patents as well most recently you
probably saw the press that bob was
awarded the Draper Pryce Draper prize of
engine from for engineering awarded by
the National Academy of Engineering
Engineers would like to think of the
Draper Pryce is our version of the nobel
and if you look at the people who have
come before Bob and you look at their
inventions you would I think resonate
with that idea the the inventors of the
jet engine the developers of Fortran
probably the first modern computer link
now some of you may curse these people
but the developers of Fortran the
developers of modern catalysts and
petrochemical engineering so Bob is an
incredible company there beside all of
these things Bob is an extraordinary
human being he has one property that has
gotten in trouble once again this Bob
never says no ever and he's here today
to deliver the lecture bio materials and
how they will change our lives up
[Applause]
thank you very much it's really a
pleasure to be able to to speak with you
today and what I'd like to do is tell
you about some of our research whenever
I talk about our research people would
always tell me that I'm talking about
the future because it's so far off but
what what I'd like to do is tell you
about how we've tried to use materials
to deliver drugs to our bodies sometimes
to very specific sites in our bodies
which might lead to new kinds of of
medical treatments and that towards the
end I'd like to actually tell you how
you can actually apply some of these
approaches with materials to actually
create create new tissues in the human
body so the first thing I want to do is
tell you a little bit about this field
of drug delivery a couple of years ago I
got asked actually actually to give a
lecture to graduate students at the
University of California at Berkeley and
I wasn't really thinking that much and
the way I started the talk I said
probably everyone here has probably
taken drugs at some point or other
that's what they all did they all
laughed but what I meant was that they'd
probably take an aspirin or things like
that and the problem is is that whenever
you do take drugs of any type the drug
level starts out very low it rises over
time reaches some type of peak and then
goes down so several hours or a day
later you repeat the same thing but the
problem with that type of delivery which
is happens for all drugs pretty much is
that those Peaks can be unsafe and those
valleys the drugs not effective and and
that the consequence of that's profound
side effects from taking drugs even the
way you're supposed to can cause many
many deaths every year the journal
American and Medical Association
estimates that over a hundred thousand
deaths each year occur because of these
kinds of adverse drug effects often
caused by this type of way so if if you
are able to deliver drugs at a steady
controlled rate to where you want to the
hope would be that that could have a
profound impact on human health and and
actually I think already even though
it's a very young field I believe it's
already doing that if one looks at this
from
purely economic standpoint in 1980 the
sales of advanced drug delivery systems
I wish I'll be talking to you about
would be about zero dollars but if you
look at last year 2001 in the United
States alone the sales of these types of
delivery systems exceeded twenty billion
dollars so it's actually moving quite
quickly and and and that's so what I'd
like to do today is tell you a little
bit about about this field and maybe
some of the things you might expect to
see sometime in the future let me see if
I do this right now do i I've never used
this computer presentation before so do
I just press this thing well no I do oh
it's up oh geez okay yeah usually I do
this and they're all I got to pleasant
surprise today that I was going to have
a much more efficient presentation for
you so anyhow this is an example of a
controlled drug delivery system it's a
nitroglycerin patch it delivers
nitroglycerin over 24 hours and so this
is kind of a one day system it's one of
the earliest ones to come out in 1982
but over half a billion of these were
used last year and you can actually one
of the great things about chemical
engineering is you can employ principles
like slow diffusion even through very
tiny systems this is a graph of a system
known as the noir plan and what you can
see is these systems are the sizes
matchsticks yet by slow diffusion
through silicon rubber you can get
released for over five years from a
single implant and and then you remove
it well I'd like to actually now go back
in time and tell you a little bit about
how I got interested in this field and
as Bob mentioned after I graduated from
MIT I I went to work with Judah Folkman
at Boston Children's Hospital and really
when I started this work that I was that
I'm going to talk about it was pretty
basic kind of stuff I was studying this
process of how blood vessels grow in the
body and I was trying to develop assays
bio assays to study that but these
processes would take a long time like 30
days and the problem is the molecules we
were studying were often large molecules
and they were destroyed rather quickly
in the body so what I was became
interested
doing to develop these bio assays was
seeing if I could have a way to slowly
deliver these these macromolecules now
in 1974 we started this work I don't
think really other than that filled
anybody cared but what happened is just
about four or five years later we'd see
the whole advent of biotechnology and
genetic engineering so for the first
time it became possible to produce large
molecular weight drugs peptides proteins
and so forth and these drugs pose very
serious drug delivery challenges you
couldn't swallow them because they were
so big very hard to take through the
skin because they're so big and if you
injected them what you'd often see are
very short lifetimes in the body but if
you wanted to use one of these types of
drugs on a chronic basis it would be
critical to have a way to deliver it in
an unaltered form and yet protect it
from harm now when we started this work
the conventional wisdom in this young
field was that you couldn't really get
large molecules through biocompatible
polymers in fact in the 1970s when you
look at quotes and I'll just show you
this one from 25 years ago when people
were describing this young field which
was then largely in the research stage
this is what they would say and I'll
just read this to you it says it's a
direct quote it says the agent to be
released is a small molecule with a
molecular weight no larger than a few
hundred one would not expect that macro
molecules for example proteins could be
released because of their extremely
small permeation rates through polymers
actually this quote was very helpful to
us in getting some of those patents that
Bob mentioned I spent several years in
the laboratory and I was able to find
that you could take certain a very
hydrophobic polymers polymers at the
absorb very little water and by
dissolving them the right kind of
solvent adding powder drug and doing
this at a very low temperature we could
make little microspheres here's one cut
in half and by using these approaches or
what we were able to show is that you
could get a release of a variety of
different molecules peptides and
proteins ranging in molecular weight
from four
thirteen thousand to a quarter of a
million for over a hundred days now in
these early studies you can see that the
release rates weren't constant so we use
some chemical engineering modeling
approaches to figure out why this was
and we're actually able to construct
microspheres that could get us
absolutely constant release and this is
an example of that where we're releasing
albumin for over 50 days when I first
started doing my work you know I mean
now I think I think this is about the
7th or 8th talk I've given this week and
I you know it but but the thing is was
when I started when I first started my
career I was not a good speaker at all
and I was very scared actually of giving
talks and the very first time I got
asked to talk at an international
meeting was in 1976 when I was a postdoc
and it was in Midland Michigan that's
where Dow and Dow Corning is and I was
actually quite nervous about it so I
stopped actually work about two and a
half weeks before the talk and I kept
practicing my 20-minute talk over and
over again into a tape recorder so
finally the day came and you know and
that was like Bob said 26 years ago so I
was quite a bit younger than I am now
and so I and I and I was giving this
talk to this you know pretty
distinguished audience of more elder
polymer scientists and engineers so I
got up and I gave the talk and actually
at the end of it I actually felt pretty
good about it I didn't forget too much
of what I wanted to say I didn't stammer
too much and so I thought when I was
done with this talk that this you know
kind of more older scientists being nice
people
would want to encourage me this young
guy so I when I got done know a whole
bunch of them came up to me after the
talk and they said well we don't believe
anything you just said
it was kind of my introduction to how
scientists sometimes interact with other
scientists at any rate it wasn't till
another three years later 1979 that a
variety of groups like at National
Institutes of Health and other places
repeated what we've done and then the
question shifted to how could this
possibly happen so Raja and Bao WA one
of my graduate students started taking
techniques that were normally used in
pathology like using a microtome and he
would cut thin sections through these
polymers and we would visualize them so
here's a five micron thin section of one
of the polymers we used ethylene vinyl
acetate and if a molecule was three
hundred molecular weight or greater it
could not diffuse from one side of this
to the other but if you put a protein in
like here's a reddish protein myoglobin
if you put that in and you cut a slice
before any release what you see is what
we call a phase separation where the
polymers here and the proteins here now
if you take one of these systems
millimeter thick system and release it
say for a year and then cut a thin
section what you see is left behind
where the red protein was are these
pores and clearly it's the way we've
made these that enable is these pores to
occur because you didn't see it two
slides ago but it turns out that these
pores you can do a lot of microscopy on
it these pores are have a lot of tight
constrictions in them and they're also
incredibly winding and tortuous so it
takes a very long time to get through
one way I explain this to people around
the country is it's kind of like driving
a car through Boston Boston has a very
high tortuosity and so if anybody's ever
been there you say they understand now
it turns out we've also done a lot of
work kind of modeling these systems and
understanding how to regulate the
kinetics of these systems and it turns
out that that by manipulating the pore
structures you can take very very tiny
systems and and get you release almost
anywhere from a day to several years in
fact the biggest problem that I have
found as a professor and getting
long-term release actually turns out not
to be the design of these systems but
rather
my ability to find a graduate student
who will do the experiment that long and
actually it turned out in the 1980s I
had a very good graduate student named
Marc Saltzman and he actually did this
experiment for over three years and then
one day first esis and then one day he
came up to me he said Bob I've been
thinking he said what will I do if this
experiment fails he said do I have to
repeat it so so we stopped the three
years in two months and five days but
I've always thought with the right
student you know we could probably go
six or seven years that's not that's not
to scare anybody but uh and actually it
turns out to be good said Marc actually
had got an endowed chair at Cornell he's
and now Yale just recruited him to head
up their a bioengineering program now
one of my goals also has been to not
just do the research but we wanted to
really try to see the work have an
impact ultimately in people and once so
one of some of my students like Larry
Brown who actually was diabetic himself
would actually develop systems in this
case for delivering insulin so here we
have a tiny system no bigger than an
aspirin pill and you can take this and
implant it in a rat and lower the blood
sugar from 400 which is diabetic to 100
which is normal and keep it there for
over a hundred days I'm going to come
back to this point a little later to
show you how you could regulate it and
this would begin to establish the invivo
feasibility of these kinds of things now
how could we get people interested
companies interested well you know it
really you know when we do these things
ourselves as professors you know we
always kind of think that what we're
doing is important and I would try to
get people interested and I could tell
you for the first nine or ten years I
was doing this absolutely nobody cared
and finally at about 1983-84 a Japanese
company actually Takeda they called up
and they said well we'd like to give you
some grant money any professor hears
that that's you know magic and and but
they said what we'd like in return is we
want to send a scientist to your lab
each year I said that's great and so
actually they did that but what they did
is that they reverse today actually then
went back and they made actually the
very first controlled release system for
a peptide and that's shown here it's
they actually developed a drug called
loop relied acetate it's a about 1,200
molecular weight and it's very powerful
drug but if they gave it by any
conventional method it was destroyed
right away so they put it in these
little micro spheres and originally they
would last for a month they were
injectable now they actually made him to
last for four months and today this is
actually the most conventional way of
treating advanced prostate cancer
endometriosis or precocious puberty it's
over a billion dollar a year product now
to get people interested in in protein
delivery that was even harder so and in
fact we couldn't get any company to be
interested in that so Alex Khlebnikov
who is the professor of chemistry and
myself actually decided to start a
company which would ultimately emerge
into Alchemy's and alchemy is working
together with genatech using this this
approach basically developed the very
first controlled release system for
protein and this is human growth hormone
which normally you have to take once a
day now you can take it once a month and
there are many many others in various
stages of clinical trials there's one
again by Alchemy's that's at the FDA
it's going through all the trials for
schizophrenia many others at various
other stages so basically we've been
able to get some of the fundamentals
done to release these kinds of molecules
at either decreasing or steady rates but
you always like to do better and one of
the things that I wanted to do was
someday to be able to make these systems
smart like safer that diabetic situation
could you ever release more drug when
you want to so a couple years ago I was
watching a TV show on and I would
usually I don't I was watching a PBS
show and and they were talking about how
microchips were made in the computer
industry and so I started thinking you
know gee this might be an interesting
way to develop chemical delivery systems
so I called up Michael CIMA who is a
professor in material science and I
asked him if he could help us and what
we came up with was this kind of design
as a prototype and instead of like a
regular chip this one contains real
chemicals that you can store and release
to the outside world
so here's the idea that basically you
have a impermeable coat down here like
an epoxy you build little wells in and
you cover them with gold this is a
cutaway you could by the way use various
materials you don't have to use these
but turns out these are pretty good in
the body at any rate this the the drugs
will stay in there for pretty much as
long as you want but if you apply just
one volt selectively to any of these
little micro pattern wires they will
actually as I'll show you dissolve the
gold and then whatever is underneath it
can come out it'll come out right away
if you put no resistance underneath it
but if I want to make it take longer to
come out I could put a polymer or gel or
something like that and and essentially
hopefully get almost any delivery
pattern so I had a very good graduate
student John Santini and he actually
designed some of these this one what
you're looking at is a United States
dime and these are the two sides of the
chip there's 34 wells on this he's now
made them he actually has a company to
do this over a hundred wells and I think
pretty soon will be over a thousand now
sometimes people ask could you put much
drug in these the answer to that really
depends on the clinical application but
a way of thinking about this is you
could probably let's say you could put a
1 cubic centimeter chip as an implant or
a pill well the way to think about that
is 50% of the volume of the chip could
actually be the drug so if you make a
conservative assumption that the density
of the drug is the density of water one
gram per cc that means you could put 500
milligrams of drug in such a system what
does that mean
5000 point 1 milligram dosages or 500 1
milligram dosages or 50 10 milligram
dosages that's a way that you might
think about it so we've made these chips
and just to look at how they work here's
an example looking at again a micrograph
of just a single well and it'll stay
like this for years
hermetically sealed the drug is in place
but if you just apply one volt to this
in 10 seconds here's what happens the
the gold the gold comes off and as soon
as it does the drug can come right out
so what we've been able to do is you
could take one drug and deliver it in
multiple
doses here's an example where we've
taken a single drug and arbitrary
released it at one and a half days all
different doses in the well at one and a
half days at two and a half days four
and a half days and five and a half days
each each different well is a different
amount and again these are purely
arbitrary we could have selected
essentially any pattern we want some day
our thinking is that you could almost
have a pharmacy on a chip let's say you
wanted to deliver multiple drugs at
multiple times and as a prototype of
that John released multiple drugs here
and here what you're seeing is drug
released at two-and-a-half days another
drug from a different well at three and
a half days this same drug from a
different well at five days and this
same drug from a different well at six
days again it's arbitrary
now since this time we've also taken
this in vivo and rats and done pretty
extensive biocompatibility studies on
these materials and they seem quite safe
in animals our long-range goals for this
which we're currently working on are to
see about ultimate applications in a
variety of diseases but some of the
things that we've been trying to do or
could for example you deliver this by
remote control like by telemetry so
probably you could open these Wells up
but by telemetry in much the same way
you open up a garage door you could open
up any individual well whenever you'd
want also what we're trying to do is
incorporate biosensors into these chips
along with a power source and a
microprocessor so that you could
essentially have a direct feedback
control system also what we hope to do
since it's a chip you could actually
download the information that you know
whenever you deliver a drug you could
actually have the information be
transmitted to your computer in your
home your doctor's office or the
hospital so all these are going to
happen in the future someday we believe
and hopefully do some very useful things
in medicine now so far what I've told
you about is how we can kind of take
materials and engineer them to do things
they couldn't do before
but another concern I've had is the
materials themselves and when I was
working in the hospital many years ago I
was very curious to see how mature
would find their way into medicine and
being a chemical engineer I guess I
always thought that the driving force
for bringing materials into medicine
would be other chemical engineers that
were before us or chemists or material
scientists but as I examined this I
found that was rarely the case almost
always the driving force for bringing
materials into medicine were like
companies and very often clinicians and
what the clinicians would do is they
actually wanted to solve a problem
relatively quickly and the way they
would do it is they would go to their
house and kind of find a household
object that resembled the organ or
tissue they wanted to fix let me explain
that and this is all true I mean people
may think it's funny but they're all
true so let me tell you about the
artificial heart which you read about a
lot in the newspapers today but you
probably don't read about the origins of
the materials so much well the origins
of all this started in 1967 at the
National Institutes of Health and and
and they're some of the clinicians we're
trying to figure out how to make an
artificial heart and one of they thought
about from a material standpoint is
something with a good flex life and they
thought what object has a good flex life
and said a ladies girdle and they said
what's it made out of polyurethane so
that's what they made the artificial
heart out of in 1967 problem is that's
what they make it out of in 2002 as well
and you can look at various journals
like the time or Newsweek or scientific
journals it doesn't really matter one of
the biggest problems in the artificial
hearts it turns out the mechanical
engineers have done a pretty good job it
beats long enough but when blood hits
the surface of the artificial heart the
ladies girdle material it can form a
clot which could go to the brain and the
patient could get a stroke and die and
yet if you think about it's something
that was designed to be a ladies girdle
it might not be you know the optimal
material to put in contact with blood
and this problem pervades all of
Medicine dialysis tubing was originally
sausage casing vascular grafts that's an
artificial blood vessel that was a
surgeon in Texas going to a clothes
store to find what he could so well with
and by the way I don't want to minimize
these approaches because they really
enabled the first wave of progress to
occur
in the 20th century but they also create
problems as obviously people know you
can't for example make vascular grafts
under six millimeters in diameter
because again blood season on natural
surface it'll clot the last one I I hope
there are no lawyers here but if you
look at breast implants
one was a lubricant and the other
actually a mattress stuffing I see
people are thinking of the logic but but
it's it's true you know I mean that
that's often how these things happen
so what we decided to do was take a very
different approach in the 1970s and that
is rather than take a material off the
shelf rather to ask the question what do
you really want in a biomaterial
from engineering standpoint from a
chemistry standpoint from a biology
standpoint and then could you synthesize
it so we picked an example and that
example had to do with biodegradable
polymer implants and the when we started
this work there was only one synthetic
polymer that had been approved by the
FDA for implantation those are the
polyester suture materials and they
dissolve like this a process we call
bulk erosion
so you uniformly distribute the drug in
the system but over time it would get
spongy and could fall apart
and that's fine for some drugs but it
could lead to bursts of drug coming out
which for example if you had a really
toxic drug like say insulin or an
anti-cancer drug this might not be so
good
so we said from an engineering
standpoint what you'd like to do is
surface erosion that's analogous to the
way a bar soap dissolves or the way an
onion peels and if you could do that the
thinking was you shouldn't get the snow
stumping not only that the design should
be very easy if you want to double the
lifetime of the device you just double
the thickness for example the challenge
was how to do it and we went through a
pretty detailed engineering design
analysis to figure out the right bonds
the right monomers the right chemical
structures I won't go through all of
that with you but other than to show you
the final answer we came up with is this
shown by this chemical structure it's
the only structure I'll show but it
turns out to be a polyanhydride that's
the bond and we pick two monomers two
units one which is very hydrophobic to
keep water out and the other slightly
less hydrophobic and we based this
particular structure on not only
chemistry but also toxicology Michael
amar
who is a professor at MIT at the time
help us figure out what monomers would
be safe in the human body and so this
was hypothesis but some of our students
like Howie Rosen synthesized these
polymers and what we found this work by
Janet Tamaro it was that basically you
can get if by by simply looking at
percent degraded or released this is
zero percent the basic acid one of the
units this is fifteen percent fifty five
percent the whole point is by simply
adjusting the ratio of these this a
millimeter thick slab will take four
years to dissolve but as you increase it
a little faster and faster with 79
percent you were all gone in two weeks
so you could simply dial in the ratio of
these monomers and it would last for
whatever length of time you want so that
would give you the opportunity to design
systems that could last anywhere from
days to literally years so I was going
to tell you we've actually over the
years been looking at a number of
applications I thought I'd show one of
them with for you this is a brain cancer
glioblastoma multiforme it's uniformly
fatal and regardless of how you treat it
the mean lifespan is less than a year so
the it's a terrible disease and the
drugs that you give the drugs that you
give for this disease are really bad
drugs and they cause a lot of side
effects the major drug that's given is a
drug called B C and you as shown here
and normally you give it intravenously
so it travels throughout the whole body
causing a lot of serious side effects on
the liver kidney and spleen so Henry
Bram and I Henry was a young
neurosurgeon at the time he's now chief
actually of neurosurgery at Johns
Hopkins but he in 1985 came to see me to
see whether we could try to apply some
of these ideas to treating brain cancer
and actually more broadly other
localized diseases which I'll mention
shortly but basically the idea that we
started talking about is could you
develop what we'll call local therapy
rather than systemic therapy and the
idea was that you could operate from now
in this case for neurosurgery operate on
the
and take the tumor out because you're
gonna do that anyhow that's what the
neurosurgeon would do but before he'd
close up the patient he'd lined the
surgical cavity with the polymer
containing B C and you that's the drug
they wanted the polymer to be degradable
so it wouldn't accumulate in the brain
to have the surface degrading a property
so it couldn't dump this toxic drug and
from animal studies they done they
wanted to last for a month and and you
could do that with these polymers by
simply adjusting the ratios of those
units at any rate so the polymer
protects the BCNU from a degradation so
if the polymer lasts for a month the
drug will last for a month but most
importantly is this concept of local
therapy high concentrations in the brain
where you want it and lower almost
non-existant concentrations in the rest
of the body where it could cause harm
now whenever you get an idea and you're
a professor I mean what you have to do
is raise money for so we would write
grants to the federal government
generally the National Institutes of
Health and our peers my peers would
review it and over the years I actually
saved a lot of their grant reviews which
were not particularly good and and I
thought I would show you a couple of
them today so I entitle this slide this
approach will not work because and in
1981 when I first wrote about this this
is purely from the polymer standpoint
the chemists would look at it and they
said well these polymers can't be
synthesized so Harry Rosen and Bob
Linhart in our lab worked out ways to
synthesize them so then two years later
the reviews came back they said well
okay they can be synthesized but these
polymers will react with encapsulating
drug you put in there so kamle young
another one of our postdocs at the time
worked out way so that wouldn't happen
by making salts and other things so a
couple years later we wrote again and
they said well but you know these
polymers are low molecular weight
they're fragile they'll break up in the
body can't be useful so I'll be dome
another one of our postdocs worked out
ways figuring out the right catalysts
and and and time and temperature
conditions in the synthesis to make them
very high molecular weight and strong
actually all these by the way made for
great doctoral theses they're post
doctoral projects oh and all these guys
actually became that did it like full
professors too
a different places anyhow the next issue
was well these are brand new materials
are certainly not going to be safe in
the body but it turns out Cato Laurencin
who is one of my students did a lot of
studies and animals showing that in fact
they were so finally we're now in 1988
and this was not actually a review I was
running one of these conferences called
the Gordon conference which are these
conferences where you actually like to
encourage a lot of discussion so being a
chemical engineer I thought it would be
fun to invite a lot of other chemical
engineers but I also thought it would be
nice to invite Henry Bram who's the
clinician because I wanted to show
people how people start we're starting
to think about this young field from a
medical standpoint so I asked Henry to
give a talk and he went over his talk
where he was showing how he was treating
this disease in animals and at the end
of his talk the number of the chemical
engineers raised their hand and they
said well dr. Bram that was a that was a
very nice talk but we've developed these
mathematical models that show that the
drug will not diffuse far enough to kill
the remaining tumor after pardon or
spelling but but at any rate Henry then
said but I just did show that it killed
the tumor and the chemical engineers
said no no that's that's not important
they said the models show it doesn't
diffuse far enough and they kind of went
back and forth about what was important
in fact it wasn't till about five years
later that Marc Saltzman developed some
better models to predict this the next
issue is that even if it did diffuse far
enough it's not a very good drug that by
the way is true and one of the hopes we
have is that with this kind of approach
you could put much better drugs in and
the Hopkins group and others are doing
that now with newer drugs like taxall
and cytokines and so forth and the next
issue was manufacturing that this would
be very difficult to manufacture and
gilford pharmaceuticals which licensed
from MIT worked those things out and
finally in 1997 the FDA actually
approved this procedure was the first
time in over 20 years a new treatment
had been approved for treating brain
cancer now actually I'd like to actually
show you what this operation looks like
but if anybody's squeamish and doesn't
like the sight of blood I'm really
serious about this you really shouldn't
look at the next two slides but what you
do is you opera this is going to be
human patients and here you put one
little disc in the brain
here and usually put seven or eight and
then close the close the tumor site you
know it's very hard to get good advice
whenever you you give a talk but a
couple years ago actually I was
lecturing to a group of chemical
engineers and my wife Laura came to the
lecture and I asked her at the end of
the talk I said what did you think of
the talk and she said well she said the
talk was okay that's actually very high
praise and but she said Bob you know you
had those two bloody slides on for 12
minutes and you explained every detail
of the operation I was kind of excited
about you know it's like our polymers
going to people and she said you
explained every detail the operation she
said I don't know if you were looking
but all those poor chemical engineers
were we're turning green and looking at
the floor so ever after that I've done
just what I did today but I do want to
tell you the sequel to this a couple
about two years ago Mike Moskowitz a
friend of mine he's a neurologist he was
running a conference called the
Princeton conference and he actually
asked if I would give the dinner speech
but you see this conference this
conference is attended pretty much by
neurosurgeons and a few neurologists and
there's all clinicians so I actually I
gave them the same talk I told him the
same story and at the end a number the
neurosurgeons came up to me and they
said you know those two bloody slides
you showed I said yes they said you
could have left those on as long as you
wanted they said that was fine but they
said those chemical formulas
that that's also also true both of them
and so now when I give the talk to
neurosurgeons it's very different you
know about what I put on at any rate to
show you a little bit of the clinical
data I mean this is by no means a cure
but there is improved safety and
efficacy and what you see is if you look
at the treated group at the end of the
year
you see about 63% survival in the
treated group 19% in the controls and at
the end of two years 31% in the treated
group and 6% in the controls and it it
does relieve suffering as well now and
like as I mentioned the FDA has approved
it for different uses now you know
whenever you do something like this
there's different milestones that maybe
you hit you know one we were excited
when we synthesized it another when it
first went into people finally when the
FDA approved it but uh about a year and
three months ago we found some I found
something out that I I guess I hadn't
expected which was that it actually got
onto national television and I'll tell
you a story on this for those of you
that aren't familiar with this so
there's this TV show I don't usually
watch it but it's called ER it's a some
people probably do watch it and it turns
out that the star of the show is a guy
named Anthony Edwards and he plays this
this clinician named Mark Greene and he
has a brain tumor by the way for those
of you that don't watch the show if you
ever watch this movie Top Gun that stars
Tom Cruise and he's Tom Cruise's partner
in that he actually didn't do too well
there either
but so at any rate so what happens in
the show is he keeps you know he was
looked like he had a very bad brain to
him he was gonna be off the show in
about two weeks so he'd go from he'd go
from Doctor to doctor and they all would
tell him you know he's off the show in a
couple weeks
and and and and and and finally he goes
to one last doctor who actually turns
out to be Susan Sarandon husband I mean
in real life or excess but in real life
but anyhow this guy when you see him and
I'll show you this video clip in a
second you sort of get the impression
you may have gone to Harvard Medical
School you'll see what I mean
but at any at any rate so I'm going to
show you this video clip from ER see if
this works
congratulations thank you sorry to keep
you waiting I met some resistance and
tumor board is that good or bad the
oncologists and radiation therapists are
having trouble embracing the future
meaning come over here they see a lesion
like yours they jump to the conclusion
it's inoperable it's not my hands
there's your tumor now as you were doing
verbal tasks there was increased blood
flow to language centers those light up
in orange as you can see while the
tumors adjacent to Broca's it hasn't
invaded yet neurosurgeon in Chicago said
that's why you're here
so you're a whopper right no yeah we'll
do an awake craniotomy you'll be
conscious and talking while I map out
Broca's and resect the tumor but the
real bonus is my ability to insert high
dosage chemotherapy wafers into the
tumor cavity and use the malignant cells
themselves to create a cancer vaccine
thank God for a second
move idiots in the tumor board are
satisfied with 12-month survival or most
of the patients on my protocol we have
disease-free for 24 months and Counting
so when can you fit him into the
schedule how about December 31st you can
ring in the New Year with a load off
your mind
brain surgeon humor right you okay yeah
it's good news very good news
[Music]
came to the right place mark so anyhow
the the the bad news about this is that
it looks like now he wants to get off
the show so they met and you know it's
about a year and a half later so his
tumor may be coming back but but but you
see that would actually probably mimic
what what may happen in real life these
these treatments extend life they
relieve suffering they probably double
lifespan but they're not a cure and so
the hope is by finding better drugs and
better materials we'll be able to do
better still also one of the exciting
things about this is now many groups are
extending it into other areas so there's
actually already another localized tumor
spinal tumor that's been approved
another one for ovarian cancers and
clinical trials and and it's being
extended to other areas as well like one
of the big areas which has been very
exciting is in the whole area of heart
disease one of the most common ways of
treating heart disease is to use balloon
angioplasty to open up a blood vessel
but the blood vessels close off over
about six months so people put in stents
these are little like Chinese finger
puzzle things the problem even they're
about twenty five percent of the times
the blood vessels close off and the
patients die so what they're now doing
and Johnson & Johnson is probably the
leader but about five companies have
done this is develop again this whole
idea of localized chemotherapy right to
the blood vessel keeping the blood
vessels open with really actually a
hundred percent open after the six-month
time period and greatly increased
survival and I think again it's only the
imagination of clinicians that as people
move forward to think about other
applications one might use the the next
example I wanted to use is actually it's
an interesting personal story you know
about seven years ago I had a postdoc
come to me named David Edwards actually
Bob recommended him to see me and David
actually had already done one postdoc
and actually had never done experiments
he was a chemical engineer extremely
bright but always had done mathematical
modeling and in fact the very first time
he came to our lab the first paper he
wrote had 300 equations in it
but then we got them interested in
thinking about other delivery problems
and one of them was to the lung and I'll
tell you a little bit about that right
now
when people take aerosols and probably
different people know people who have
taken a metered dose inhalers or
nebulizers you generally have it's
unbelievably inefficient you're lucky if
you get 5% of the drug from the device
into the lung the reason for that is
you've got these tiny aerosols usually
liquids and they've got enormous surface
area so they aggregate it's kind of like
wet sand in fact more recently people
have even come up with dry powder
inhaler x' but because aerosol ization
is so inefficient I'd say over the last
10 years we've seen about 40 different
companies develop better through
mechanical engineering better aerosol
icers better devices and the reason they
do that is because if you could make
them better maybe you could go from like
5% to 8% or 9% that's pretty much what's
been done and that would mean you'd save
a lot on the drug but also you can make
the device a lot smaller people want to
use these for insulin and other things
and you don't want to carry around a
giant inhaler but David came up with a
very different way of looking at that he
said everybody else has looked at the
device nobody's looked at the aerosol
and you might think well how could you
redesign water or other aerosols but see
what everybody had been doing was
designing these tiny aerosols but what
David thought is what if we make really
big aerosols but unlike regular air and
first of all why might bigger be better
well the idea bigger could be better
because they wouldn't aggregate as much
right there's a lot less surface area so
if you think about it what basketballs
aren't going to aggregate like wet sand
also we thought that when they went into
the lung
they might get cleared a lot more slowly
because see the clearance mechanism our
macrophages these cells and now they're
sort of seeing a big meal rather than a
small meal they'll just take them longer
to eat it but if you made a big aerosol
the conventional wisdom is it won't work
it'll settle in the back of the throat
so what David did he did a lot of
modeling studies came up with the idea
he'll make a big aerosol but make it
incredibly light and know there's
everybody had made before our aerosols
with the density of one gram per cc like
the density of water whether it was a
liquid or a powder he said well let's
make the density point one and what Jeff
her cash and other Xan
lab did was come up with mace to make
these aerosols and if you think about it
what they're gonna look like see a
regular aerosol looks like a little golf
ball or a little baseball what we're now
doing is making wiffle balls and so they
made these and what was really exciting
about them is you could take a
conventional inhaler and this is in
vitro if you looked at the regular
aerosol you get about five or six
percent in David's aerosol you get about
sixty percent in ten times more that's
in vitro if you go in vivo and you look
at different lobes of the lung what you
see is each time and you get the same
number of particles you get about 10
times more particles deposited with the
poorest ones than the non-porous ones if
you translate that to the amount of drug
that goes to the human body let's take
insulin it turns out that if you use a
control or non-porous one you basically
get almost no insulin level but if you
take an injection and compare it to the
poorest ones in a single whiff you get
eighty-six percent of the drug that
you'd normally get by an injection and
if you make the aerosol as a certain
size here a single whiff of insulin
lasted for days and David actually with
a number of our students started a very
successful company advanced inhalation
research based on this and in fact for
the people who invested in that they
actually even if for those of you to
follow business they actually made a
thousandfold IRR which is an annualized
return so they did pretty well and but
basically what he was able to do in
starting this company which is now part
of Alchemy's is make aerosol and here is
one of them delivering for three days
and about eight different ones are now
in clinical trials so people are using
this now for asthma drugs for insulin
and clinical trials human growth hormone
and clinical trials and many others and
actually one of the nice things that's
interesting is David ended up making a a
reasonable amount of money for this and
actually ended up buying a building on
Boylston Street right opposite the
Boston Public Library and set up this
foundation it's like a four-story
building for teaching poor kids and in
Boston arts and dance and things like
that so it's actually a very nice
personal story to see him go all that
way and actually he was elected to the
National Academy
engineering at the age of of 39 for it
for this now the last thing I want to
talk about was possibly creating new
tissues let me motivate that by showing
you a child who has liver failure that
child was a patient of my close
collaborator jaiva Conti and the the
problem is when somebody has a problem
like liver failure the only way a child
like that can live is somebody else has
to die and then you do a transplant and
that's what she does but the problem is
take liver failure there's a giant donor
shortage last year 30,000 people died of
liver failure there are only enough
donors for 10 percent of those and so
because of that Sam Sammy you got my
eight-year-old son that's coming to the
lecture he wants to be engineer someday
so but he's asking his mom questions so
at any rate and actually what he told
what he throw when he had to do his
autobiography is actually very
interesting when he was 7 he wrote to
the teachers when he grows up he's going
to be an engineer and then he and then
on weekends
he's going to go to take his children to
MIT and show them his lab I don't know
where he got that from
so a a a a a at any rate so the I so
because of that Jay and I came up with
this idea that maybe you could take
isolated cells in fact we were doing a
lot with stem cells which I didn't put
up here but you could take stem cells
and convert them into the right cell
type and then what we wanted to do is
have like a polymer scaffold and again
I'm not going to go into all the
engineering of it but the idea is if you
could put the cells close enough
together several groups like the cells
group at Berkeley is shown few cells are
smart and so if you take mammary
epithelial cells put them close to
enough together they can actually form a
sandai and make milk and and so what we
did is we want to create polymer
scaffolds with the right signals and the
right proximity to allow the cells to
reorganize grow them in a bioreactor and
then ultimately make a new tissue this
was the idea now to do this we could
make the polymer fibers which you see
here with liver cells on them and and
actually you can prasad Chaucerian our
group actually worked out ways to make
them in almost any shape so here's a
shape of a nose and and someday you
might envision using like computer-aided
design CAD cam techniques like if
somebody wanted a nose like say an
upturned nose or hook note you could
make almost any kind of nose you want
and and and and make it into it so so
how's the idea let me illustrate some of
the challenges in tissue engineering and
why it's a bit different than than other
fields of just cell culture so I'll pick
the idea of making new blood vessels and
this was the work of several people but
first one of the challenges this is to
make very small diameter blood vessels
which had never been done before so one
of the challenges to make little tubes
three millimeters in diameter
Dave Mooney one of our graduate students
who's now professor at Michigan did that
made these tiny little tubes then Jen
minghao who was a chemist from Harvard
George Whitesides lab and now postdoc
with me and now professor at Case
Western then worked out ways to alter
their chemistry of the surfaces of these
polymers in such a way you could get a
high cell attachment then Laura
Nicholson who really led this project
she was an MD PhD now at now she's a
Duke she actually wanted to mimic a real
blood vessel so what she do is put
smooth muscle cells those are the cells
that
are in the outer part of the blood
vessel and then endothelial cells which
are on the inner side that's the EC of
the blood vessel but the real trick to
this see if you've ever gone to a
biology lab or a medical lab and you
look at how they grow the cells the
cells just sit there maybe there's less
mild shaking or whatever but they pretty
much sit there in an incubator or shake
flask and nobody I could ever get this
type of stuff to work a few people even
did flow but what Laura said is you know
that's not what's happening in our body
our body they're not just sitting in an
incubator what happens is they're
actually hooked up to a pump you know
your blood vessels in the body they're
hooked up to a pulsatile pump your heart
so she actually created a whole cell
culture system very different than
before where she'd actually create bio
reactors in such a way that she'd would
make these tubes be exposed to pulsatile
radial stress and in particular the
design she developed is shown here where
she figured out the right medium here's
a pump that will beat at 160 five-minute
beats per minute like an embryonic heart
right into these little vessels over an
eight week period and at the end of that
you get these tiny little vessels like
this and if you examine them they have
all the characteristics of a regular
blood vessel the same amount of collagen
they're actually quite strong which
should have been a big challenge before
they can withstand 2,000 millimetres of
pressure of mercury you can actually
suture them into an animal and keep them
there and they have the same
pharmacology as a normal blood vessel
and you could take the toughest animal
model a pig
and by doing angiography you can keep
the blood vessels open for months one of
the big challenges is getting enough of
a cell source of the endothelial cells
and recently as children at Levenberg in
our lab actually worked out a way to
using human embryonic stem cells as a
starting point work out ways to actually
now make endothelial cells in large
quantities and the hope is at some point
this could go into humans a second
example I wanted to pick is cartilage
there's over a million operations each
year where people need new cartilage and
our ID in fact this is already being
done now we're working on this
clinically is you can take a few cells
from a patient maybe from their ear by
an arthroscopy and then you could make a
scaffold
any shape you want and and and and it
shouldn't reject if they're their own
cells so Chuck Lacan T one of our
collaborators actually did this on nude
mice where shouldn't reject and here
here he redid this guy's skull here he
redid this guy's cheek the top guy and
if you open the animals up they have the
same they have white glistening
cartilage and as all the biochemical
characteristics of Cardinals it by the
way is not perfect doesn't have as good
a mechanical strength as normal in fact
Lisa Frieden Gordana Vanya act
Novakovich in our laboratory are working
on ways of using bio reactors again like
sort of like the blood vessel work to
apply the right stresses so that someday
maybe we can do things where you can
have the right mechanical loads but even
so you can begin to think about using
these for plastic surgery so Linda
Griffith when she was a postdoc with us
we were working in this case with Joe
Upton who's a plastic surgeon and he
sees children that don't have ears so
you want to make a new ear so Linda
actually worked out a scaffold in the
design of a human ear here's a scanning
electron micrograph of it at very high
magnification these fibers will
ultimately dissolve and you'll
ultimately get tissue here and Chuck
Vacanti
who collaborated with us at UMass
actually didn't put these on humans but
did put them on rabbits and here is the
rabbit with the human ear and you might
ask why do we do this to rabbits but the
reason we do it to rabbits is of course
someday we want to do it to people and
this was the first patient it's a
twelve-year-old boy there's a number of
years ago but if you look at him closely
notice he has no chest covering his
heart but like other twelve-year-old
boys he likes to play baseball but if he
were ever hitting in the chest with the
baseball he could die
so actually Jay my collaborator operated
on him we made a scaffold to make a new
chest for him took his own cells and
actually did make a brand new chest now
a couple years ago after this was done
Businessweek decided to do a big
front-page feature on tissue engineering
and inside they actually featured this
child who was then 16 years old and six
feet tall skateboarding now none of the
clinicians like that but but the point
was he was doing fine and and we'd begun
applying these to many other area
as well also what we wanted to do mit is
a terrific technology transfer office so
we've licensed our patents to a number
of companies and tried to work with them
in different ways one of these companies
have actually now gotten approval using
these polymer cell approaches to
actually make new skin for burn victims
and this is now FDA approved let me give
you a very positive example of that so
here you're gonna be looking at a two
year old boy who's badly burned but what
you can do is take this system which is
a polymer scaffold with a neonatal
dermal fibroblasts put it on the child
at the time of injury now let's come
back three weeks later and now let's go
back six months later so this is just an
example of what we hope to see happen
someday with more widespread but it
gives you an idea of what can happen
here now the very final example I'd like
to do in terms of closing the talk is a
spinal cord repair here Aaron Levesque
one of our graduate students has been
working material Sciences actually
worked very closely with Evan Schneider
at Harvard Medical School and what she
wanted to do here is actually design a
polymer that was very much like the
spinal cord so she created an outer
portion that using different material
science techniques that could provide
axonal guidance an inner part that was
very porous that you could actually put
what's called neuronal stem cells in let
me show you a little bit about what they
look like so here's the scaffold it's
like a little cylinder here's the
poorest part on the inside here's the
oriented part on the outside so here's
the animal model we use she actually
would make paraplegic rats did about 50
of them and there's actually ways to
quantitate this but I'm just going to
show you a video and what she did is she
took out a portion of the spinal cord
and and the idea is that would make the
rat paraplegic she did controls where
she'd put the scaffold by itself where
she'd put the cells by themselves or
just nothing and then she would insert
this is a four millimeter system system
right in the defect to see what would
happen now these couple of caveats these
defects are none of these models are
perfect first the rat secondly we're
putting these in within 24 hours after
injury but what I wanted
has now show you a video just of
actually one of the average controls and
one of the average experiments to show
you what these look like about 70 days
later so here's the control focus on the
hind legs where it's like I say
paraplegic he's gonna be dragging them
and also notice the pause if you
quantitate this this guy probably has a
BBB score of about five again he's
paralyzed
okay now we're going to go to the
experiment and here's the experiment
where notice the hind legs and now us
will notice the pause so this is about a
13 he's no it's not a cure by any means
but certainly he's able to walk much
much better and would like to say
there's about 13 experiments about 37
controls again focused on the appearance
of the paws as well okay
so again this is a very early stage and
it's animals not people but again I
think it fits sort of what I hope the
title of the talk meant and that's sort
of how I'd like to end this that we've
probably raised a lot more questions
than we've answered there's a lot of
things and I think that's one of the
great things about MIT where there's
just so much important research to do
there's so much we don't understand
about these areas at the same time we
like to think that at least this field
has moved a little bit further and that
people are beginning to start to use
principles like this in ways that can
begin to relieve relieve suffering and
prolong life thank you very much
I'm sure Bob would be absolutely a few
questions if there are some
[Applause]
that's great we choose problems you know
I guess what I've tried to think about
is I've thought about projects over the
years was something that in the one hand
would be at a relatively early stage you
know that in other words where but to
pick a kind of idea that would almost be
a dream idea but that if we were
successful could have a profound impact
on things in the future and so it leads
to the kinds of problems that I guess I
would sort of could lead to what I'll
call sort of a core technology you know
it's interesting if I look at at almost
every one of the projects that we talked
about like releasing large molecules the
first time I thought about I thought
well maybe we'll be able to release
insulin someday turned out still not
releasing insulin clinically but because
we kind of established a lot of basic
principles it could be used for a lot of
things same thing with tissue
engineering you know the original target
for that was treating liver disease and
we're not even close but but the fact is
it because these principles are there we
or others can begin to thing think about
treating a lot of diseases and and I
think that that's largely what we've
tried to do is try to pick problems
where we can maybe make it do some
research at an early stage that if it's
successful opens the door for us and
others to think about you know many many
different directions so the question how
can we apply a voltage to the chip when
it's in the body so again there's
several levels of this in the early
studies what we've done is simply use
wires and have them come out but in the
long run what we do is basically it's
it's the same way you open up a byte
telemetry in other words you basically
would have a little microprocessor power
source on the chip that you could just
activate by remote control
so you'd have all those units into in
the chip and they're actually being
built built right now it's like I said
it's pretty pretty standard electrical
kinds of approaches any other questions
let's thank pop again yeah well it's
also an excellent question not you know
it's interesting when I look back to my
career and I and my degree of
uncertainty about what I want to do I
got my degree in 1974 and at that time
almost all my there was sort of this
energy crisis supposedly you know if you
were had a car then and you were waiting
you'd have to wait two hours in the gas
station to get to get gas and in line
and and that's what a lot of my friends
did and I remember thinking about doing
that but I just had trouble getting
excited about I guess working in an auto
company and and I know I mean it wasn't
that bad but I mean I I remember going
to Baton Rouge and other places and
thinking about it and I really didn't
know what I want to do you know I
actually applied I was very interested
in teaching chemistry education I'd
spent a lot of time as a graduate
student helped me get a school started
for poor kids and working on a chemistry
education I applied to a lot of schools
like City College in New York and even
actually some pretty crummy schools and
they actually wouldn't even look at my
application you know I really was
interested in doing that finally one of
the and I applied for some faculty
positions but I thought my ideas at the
time even though I got a couple of
offers we're not very good ideas so I
didn't do that and finally one of the so
I finally started thinking about maybe
working in a hospital because I was
always interested in maybe trying to do
some things that I felt would help
people and also I was interested in
learning some biology and so I one of
the postdocs in my lab at the time Barry
boo now actually suggested writing to
Judah Folkman and you know that so I did
and when I went over to see him I mean
it's kind of the lowest paying job by
far but I was really excited about his
ideas and about the possibility of doing
something in that area and so that's
what I did
you